las all but acción puede tener un efecto
estabilizante en una base con jugada
aquí tenemos una molécula de agua si el
agua dona un protón los electrones en
rosa se quedarán en el oxígeno lo que le
da al oxígeno una carga formal negativa
formando así la base conjugada del agua
que es el avión hidróxido el hidróxido
puede ser estabilizado por un solvente
entonces si el agua es nuestro solvente
dibujaré algunas moléculas de agua
aquí tenemos una molécula de agua y
dibujaré otra por aquí
sabemos que el agua es un solvente polar
porque el oxígeno tiene una carga
parcial negativa y los hidrógenos tienen
una carga parcial positiva debido a que
el oxígeno es más electro negativo que
el hidrógeno y ahora tenemos una
situación en donde las cargas opuestas
se atraen la carga parcial positiva del
hidrógeno en el agua es atraída a la
carga negativa del oxígeno en el
hidróxido así ocurre una fuerza de
atracción entre las cargas opuestas y
esa fuerza de atracción ayuda a
estabilizar la carga negativa en el
avión hidróxido aquí tenemos otra
molécula de agua parcial negativo y
parcial positivo así que tenemos otra
fuerza que nos ayuda a estabilizar la
carga negativa en el hidróxido entre más
moléculas de
es decir entre más moléculas de solvente
tengamos sólo matando a nuestra unión
más estable es la base conjugado si
analizamos estos cuatro compuestos para
el agua
este protón tiene un valor de pk
de aproximadamente 15.7 para el etanol
de 16 para el isopropanol este protón
tiene un valor de pk
de 17 y finalmente para el tétanos este
protón tiene un valor de pk a de 18
recuerden entre más bajo es el pk más
fuerte es el ácido así que el agua es el
ácido más fuerte de estos 4 porque tiene
un valor más bajo de pk
y si el agua es el ácido más fuerte
significa que su base conjugada es la
más estable así que el año hidróxido es
la base con jugada más estable y podemos
acomodar más moléculas de agua a su
alrededor el año ni hidróxido es el
mejor para ser soltado por nuestro
solvente y eso tiene que ver con algo
llamado impedimento estético unido a
este oxígeno cargado negativamente
tenemos un hidrógeno muy pequeño si
observamos las otras bases conjugadas
este es el año el tóxico que es la base
conjugada del etanol aquí tenemos un ch
2 y luego tenemos un ch 3 ch2 y ch 3
necesitan más espacio que un hidrógeno y
conforme bajamos podemos ver que hay más
impedimento estético este carbono está
unido
un hidrógeno pero también está unido a
un ch 3 y otros ch 3 tenemos más cosas
que se interponen en el camino y
finalmente para la última base conjugada
este es el año en término óxido tenemos
un carbono unido a un ch3 ch3 y otros
ch3 esos grupos voluminosos impiden que
haya una interacción entre las moléculas
del solvente y la base conjugada si
dibujamos una molécula de agua aquí
habrá un poco de estabilidad
sabemos que el oxígeno es parcialmente
negativo y los hidrógenos son
parcialmente positivos entonces existe
una fuerza de atracción entre las cargas
opuestas y eso ayuda a estabilizar la
base conjugada el problema es que estos
grupos ch3 que son muy
nos impiden que otras moléculas de agua
ayuden a estabilizar a esta base
conjugada eso significa que el año
termino óxido es la base con jugada
menos estable y conforme subimos
disminuye el impedimento estético de
tres grupos voluminosos luego dos grupos
voluminosos después un grupo y
finalmente sólo tenemos un hidrógeno así
que al disminuir el impedimento estético
aumenta la capacidad de nuestro solvente
para soltar a nuestro año y
estabilizarlo por lo tanto el año
hidróxido es el más estable en el
solvente y como es el más estable eso
significa que el agua donará más
fácilmente su protón y por eso es que
observamos el valor más bajo de t